[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono sicura che se mi desse la
possibilità di controllare i vostri
telefoni troverei quelle foto li le foto
del cibo ormai esistono proprio i corsi
per imparare a fotografare il cibo se
tutto va bene i ragazzini sognano di
fare i food blogger ma la cosa che mi
spaventa realmente che tra vent'anni
nessuno saprà più con quale fase lunare
è meglio seminare le patate come
friggere come dio comanda le zeppole o
pittore che dir si voglia ma soprattutto
quali sono le radici che ci legano alla
terra tra tutti i modi che avevo per non
perdere le tradizioni e per restare
legata alla mia terra
io ho scelto di dedicarmi
all'agricoltura che può sembrare una
scelta di tendenza ma nel mio caso è
stato un lungo e complesso percorso
interiore che mi ha portata prima
lontana da casa per prendere il famoso
pezzo di carta per poi tornare e cercare
di metterlo a frutto nel miglior modo
possibile
nella mia sorrento questa cosa che
tornare a casa dopo aver studiato
lavorato fuori all'estero venga vista in
maniera negativa non va bene perché
tornare a casa non è codardia tornare a
casa è un atto d'amore e tornare a casa
trovando un modo per dare qualcosa
indietro alla terra che ci ha dato tanto
è un atto d'amore da condividere e
comunicare per far sì che la percezione
di questo concetto cambi il mio di
ritorno a casa è stato un trauma
dopo cinque anni al nord con una nuova
testa sulle spalle una laurea in
un'università prestigiosa non vedevo
l'ora di tornare a casa a vedere il mare
tutti i giorni spaccare il mondo
non avevo idea di cosa mi sarebbe
successo ci ho provato ho provato a
farmi stare bene le opportunità
lavorative che mi si aprivano davanti ma
onestamente a un certo punto ho
preferito fare di testa mia e di testa
mia ma soprattutto di braccia mie mi
sono messa
della terra inizialmente io ma anche
tutti gli altri pensavamo sarebbe stato
il passatempo di una stagione un ospizio
in attesa che è una cosa un po più
normale logica per una come me sarebbe
arrivato all'orizzonte invece non è
andata così
io ogni giorno imparato imparo ancora
tante cose non solo da un punto di vista
strettamente pratico ma anche da un
punto di vista più ampio
io ho imparato quanto l'agricoltura fa
bene al territorio le famiglie e bambini
perché riuscire a riqualificare un
territorio che soffre dell'abbandono di
giovani ormai scoraggiati e riuscire a
dare nuove destinazioni e prospettive a
luoghi che vivono normalmente di un
turismo vecchio stile
sono cose che suonano complicate
sono cose che richiedono tanta passione
tantissima dedizione un forte senso di
appartenenza
eppure la soddisfazione che ne deriva
può essere veramente immensa fare un
mestiere tradizionale non vuol dire
tornare indietro perché avere radici
salde e tradizioni salver rende
possibile creare un valore aggiunto
altrimenti impensabile
esattamente come le piante senza radici
e senza terreno fatta eccezione per
litro monica non potrebbero né crescere
nemmeno tar è frutto fare l'agricoltore
oggi non è più un mestiere da persone di
poca cultura da persone lo studiate e
esattamente l'opposto
siamo in un settore che offre delle
grandi opportunità e che ha bisogno di
professionalità ben formate quando mi
capita che mi chiedono un consiglio in
merito all'università
io dico sempre che ci sono due concetti
alla base
il primo è facilissimo non fate o non
fate fare questi figli università se non
avete voglia di studiare non scegliete
giurisprudenza soltanto perché è rimasta
forse ancora per poco una delle poche
facoltà non a numero chiuso perché per
quanto siamo un popolo
estremamente polemico inclini al litigio
io non credo che avremo bisogno di tutti
questi avvocati
il secondo concetto fondamentale è che
bisogna togliersi dalla testa l'idea che
se si inizia a studiare una determinata
facoltà si finirà per fare il lavoro che
ci eravamo posti come obiettivo
all'inizio perché il 99 per cento delle
volte non andrà così
siamo di fronte ad un profondo
cambiamento di tutti i settori
c'è una fluidità delle professioni che
attraversa veramente tutti e al giorno
d'oggi non è pensabile fare avere
un'immagine da agricola senza marketing
senza comunicazione senza social media
senza nemmeno parlare l'inglese un
laureato in psicologia può essere il
motore trainante e l'anima di un
progetto di agricoltura sociale così
come io con una laurea in marketing
ho scelto di iniziare un percorso di
comunicazione volto alla
riqualificazione del contadino e delle
tradizioni della mia terra anche della
lingua napoletana
io la chiamo lingua
io lo sapevo niente di germinazione di
fasi lunari di biodiversità
pensavo che a calmare le piantine quasi
cenno con le donne volesse dire metterle
a fianco alle canne di bambù è invece la
terra mi ha travolto
l'agricoltura è riuscita a trasformare
quello che prima era un vulcano di
emozioni che io non sapevo nemmeno come
gestire figuriamoci come esprimerlo
perché prima ancora di iniziare a
coltivare
io ho iniziato a fare quello che sapevo
fare meglio comunicare
ho iniziato a raccontare la mia
esperienza tutti i giorni sui social e
sul mio blog
e stato così che nel giro di poco tempo
mi sono ritrovata sui giornali dietro
una cattedra in televisione a ricoprire
ruoli istituzionali e su questo palco
chiariamo io considero la mia per
esperienza il mio percorso parte
necessaria e fondamentale di tutto senza
non sarei qui se non avessi lasciato la
mia terra non avrai capito il reale
valore
e se non avessi aperto e strutturato la
mia testa studiando per cinque anni non
riuscirei a dare un valore aggiunto a
questo mestiere perché il punto
fondamentale che l'agricoltura ha
bisogno di professionisti e di menti
prima ancora oltre che di braccia
nel mio caso prima o poi dopo un po
tutto mi annoiava ogni lavoro in
relazione umana ma su questo preferisco
inserire con l'agricoltura non è stato
così perché ogni giorno la mia curiosità
trova nuovi stimoli e quando tutto
sembra calmarsi appiattirsi la mia
creatività arriva e mi trovo a nuovi
progetti in cui buttarmi a capofitto non
sono l'unica che si dedica ha deciso di
dedicarsi all'agricoltura
la prima volta che sono uscito sul
giornale mi sentivo tacco fita poi
effettivamente ho capito che non era
così perché ho conosciuto talmente tanti
giovani in agricoltura con delle idee e
dei progetti bellissimi che ho capito
che non ero la sola l'ulteriore botto al
mio ego contadino l'ho avuta quando mio
amico mi ha detto sai mia nonna
collezione articoli che parlano di
giovani in agricoltura età va beh allora
posso smettere di sentirmi importante
in italia ci sono oltre 55 mila aziende
guidate da giovani under 35
siamo una volta tanto leader in europa
per questa cosa e questo trend viene
rispecchiato anche dalla quantità di
giovani che decidono di continuare il
loro percorso educativo in agricoltura
non soltanto nella facoltà di agraria ma
anche già negli istituti professionali
dopo le medie nello scorso anno
scolastico 2017 2018 sono stati 45556 i
giovani che hanno scelto questa strada è
stato il record del quinquennio per
dedicarsi all'agricoltura per chi ha
un'idea imprenditoriale è anche
possibile avere accesso ai fondi messi a
disposizione dalla comunità europea
infatti nello scorso anno nello scorso
biennio quindi 2016 2017 sono state sono
arrivate più di 30mila domande da
giovani under 40 per avere accesso ai
fondi messi a disposizione
quindi che si chiama del psr di piano di
sviluppo rurale di questa di queste 30
mila domande il 61 per cento venivano
dal sud
stiamo parlando quindi di un'opportunità
reale per lo sviluppo del mezzogiorno
perché il rilancio del sud può e deve
partire dalla capacità di riuscire
finalmente a sfruttare le immense
risorse paesaggistiche culturali e
ambientali che abbiamo perché se
riusciamo a dare un'opportunità
l'agricoltura di qualità all
enogastronomia al turismo sarà possibile
anche creare un'opportunità non soltanto
per chi ha un'idea imprenditoriale ma
anche per chi vuole trovare
un'occupazione anche solo temporanea
devo toccare un argomento complicato
perché che le donne siano multitasking è
risaputo poi che ci vantiamo di esserlo
nelle discussioni tra muovendo hanno
ormai è veramente la base per quello che
ho potuto vivere io in prima persona in
agricoltura
mi sono resa conto che la
multifunzionalità femminile viene fuori
ancora in maniera più forte perché sono
quasi sempre le donne che riescono a
coniugare le attività agricole
tradizionali con quelle che vengono
chiamate le attività extra agricole
non mi riferisco soltanto gli
agriturismi ma anche a progetti di
agricoltura sociale
le code fattorie didattiche su tutti ma
anche l'educazione alimentare nel mio
personale caso non sono ancora nella
fase vero e proprio di una fattoria
didattica ma mi sono ritrovata spesso a
lavorare con le scuole e ho iniziato con
i bambini piccoli proprio quelli delle
scuole primarie soprattutto nelle città
questi bambini hanno sempre meno
coscienza di quale sia la reale
provenienza del cibo che mangiano
io parlo di un percorso educativo che
deve partire proprio dalle basi perché a
me è capitato di sentirmi chiedere
destra ma di che colore sono i ravanelli
o addirittura ma le carote crescono
sugli alberi
il passo necessario e fondamentale
dopo questo è quello di parlare di
stagionalità
perché per quanto possano essere
discutibili i gusti dei genitori è
giusto che i bambini sappiano qual è il
momento giusto per mangiare ogni cibo
magari saranno proprio loro ad aprire
gli occhi ai genitori con i ragazzi più
grandi si possono e si devono affrontare
anche temi più complessi come l'apporto
nutrizionale la stagionalità anche in
senso un po più articolato perché i
concetti come biologico km zero filiera
corta non devono essere visti come
concetti astratti o come troppo
complicati per entrare nelle case che
altrimenti un domani avremo sulle nostre
tavole sempre le stesse cose è sempre lo
stesso sapore
personalmente poi mi sono resa conto che
la sensibilità femminile ha un ruolo
molto importante anche nel contatto con
il cliente sono riuscita nei mesi ormai
posso quasi dire negli anni a convertire
le famiglie che mi seguono ad uno stile
di vita molto più in linea con quelli
che sono i tempi della natura senza
forzature settimana dopo settimana i
miei clienti anche senza incontrarsi
condividono attraverso me ricette idee
esperienze che hanno avuto nel trovare i
prodotti e in buona parte anche chi non
ha mai mangiato la mia verdura per
motivi vari ed eventuali viene reso
partecipe di questo processo attraverso
la condivisione che faccio della mia
esperienza sui social avviamente tutto
questo è molto romantico molto nobile ma
è possibile soprattutto nell'agricoltura
multifunzionale trovare anche delle
buone opportunità di guadagno per nostra
fortuna gran parte dei consumatori sta
diventando più sensibile sta scegliendo
di privilegiare il benessere rispetto a
quella che può essere l'intensità delle
culture
il boom della cultura vegetariana e
vegana è un esempio ma non è
assolutamente il solo basti pensare ai
prodotti agricoli italiani più esportati
come il vino i formaggi per capire che
un'agricoltura di qualità si è
affiancata da professionalità
agronomiche e commerciali può essere
veramente la chiave del successo
imprenditoriale
c'è un altro importantissimo
insegnamento che l'agricoltura mi ha
dato e del valore del tempo siamo
abituati a dire ea sentirci dire mi
mandi quel file mi giri quella foto e ci
aspettiamo che questa cosa succeda in un
attimo che file pesantissimi passino da
una parte all'altra del mondo nel giro
di un soffio in natura non è così vi
posso garantire che tutto e subito
esiste i gravissimi casi come quello di
quando le cavolate decidono di attaccare
un campo di broccoli in quel caso vi
posso garantire che ci vuole un attimo
non c'è più un broccolo l'estate scorsa
una mia cliente mi ha detto vorrei
mangiare i fagiolini bianchi e gli ho
detto perfetto siamo ancora nel periodo
giusto per i semino ma dovrai aspettare
un mese e mezzo è proprio questo quello
che abbiamo perso il tempo e la pazienza
di aspettarlo
non è soltanto una questione di
opportunità e di business ma una
questione di rieducazione al lavoro e
alla vita perché altrimenti ci assistere
a un su e faremo a quello che ci rende
sempre isterici esauriti scontenti
corriamo ad esser sinistra senza neanche
sapere bene dove stiamo andando poi a un
certo punto riuscire a ridare valore al
tempo è un'opportunità che in tempi di
scarsità del lavoro industriale come
quello in cui stiamo vivendo ci deve far
riflettere perché in un paese con la più
alta biodiversità del mondo come il
nostro il ritorno alla terra non è
un'utopia ma è la principale sfida per
le giovani generazioni e lo sarà anche
per quelle future
l'importante è cominciare san francesco
diceva comincia dalle cose semplici
continua con le necessarie e ti
scoprirai a fare l'impossibile
ed io aggiungo a fare l'impossibile con
i sogni nel cuore e la terra sotto le
unghie
[Applauso]